okay so she
did not like approve for the green card
[Music]
the moment brandon and julia had been
waiting for
didn't turn out how they would have
hoped but there is still hope
let me explain as brandon mentioned the
immigration office did not approve
julia's green card but they also didn't
deny it we're kind of just on a hold
but i feel like we're this close this
close maybe this close before i go
russia
okay i get that this is a lot of
pressure on julia in particular but
she and brandon have been thinking worst
case scenario
i'm just scared since they got news of
the interview
but if i i'm not approved then i go rush
and this is broken me
divorce oh my god if something didn't
dark hype
i start yelling i start to yell these
people don't start yelling
yeah that wouldn't help look i'm not one
to deny reality
but there is power in your words so they
might want to consider
giving more energy to what they want to
happen instead of what they don't
julia even asked brandon if he would go
back to russia with her
and his response was hilarious but
real and you would really want me to
immigrate to russia where it's like hard
enough
for i mean you kind of left there didn't
you we'll get into what this green card
situation means for the couple in just a
few
plus you want to reduce the boost angela
finally told michael she is getting a
breast reduction
on the day of her surgery they'll be up
perky but you won't be able to pull on
like you like
pull on them ouch
this news got michael so upset that he
called his brother over to have a
sit-down conversation about it
nigeria men value big boobs
it's part of the reason why i got
attractive
to angela on the first day you know
i saw a profile picture i loved it oh
goodness
please don't let angela hear that
hey 90 day fans fam it's malicia
yeah i'm not gonna lie this week's
episode was a bit
slow but what i'm learning with 90 days
that
you got to appreciate the build up
sometimes you know because there were
some key moments
oh my god now my heart's jumping now my
heart jumping let's start with brandon
julia and her jumping heart
they went to the immigration office for
julia's green card interview
which was big this interview is her last
step toward becoming a permanent u.s
resident
i hope this is day go quickly and now
let me
come here after green card and say
[Music]
unfortunately julia did not come out
doing the dance
after spending about two hours inside
they revealed that her green card
wasn't approved now the big question is
what does that even mean well here's how
brandon explained it
there's apparently a brand new like
requisite for the affidavit of support
a brand new document that might be
needed
and even the officer doesn't know
like what it is yet what exactly the
details are
she said what's gonna happen is either
in two weeks we'll get a letter and
it'll say you're approved or they'll
just request for more information
and then i guess we'll have to submit
that evidence that information
but if she didn't know how we know yeah
so basically it's not as bad as it
sounds
that's what i'm getting like i said
earlier there is still hope
they said it was approvable so that's
mainly positive i mean once they figure
out we meet the criteria
for the new regulations i guess we'll
get it yeah julia was not feeling the
positivity
and this is make me angry and scared and
brandon's eye roll right here
is everything i don't see why they
wouldn't get approved
but i'm also not an immigration lawyer
so
i guess we just have to wait and see in
the meantime
let's move on to our girl angela who on
the day of her weight loss surgery
was still smoking cigarettes joe do not
open your damn mouth when savage spent a
cigarette
after the doctor told her to stop he
literally
explained to her how dangerous it is to
do that before an operation
smoking is a i'm taking this are you
serious no i'm taking them it's a huge
risk
uh smoking causes decreased blood flow
causes increased infection
which leads eventually to death
wow yeah wow
she had to sit with that for a second
wow but
like her friend jojo said she can't tell
her no
angela is angela and she's her own boss
well luckily in this case we know for a
fact that she ends up okay
but y'all at home do not do that at this
point
angela surgery is just hours away and
she's freaking out
on top of that she calls michael to tell
him
she's reducing some of his favorite
assets
they they were concerned about uh
my boobs are way too big
as a woman i know that this is one of
those conversations
where you listen out more for what he
doesn't say rather than what he says
now at first angela was being petty
beating around the bush trying to make
michael jealous
she told him that dr obang her doctor
who she thinks looks like michael
had to medically massage her
he wasn't massaging your boobs he was
medically examining them
because they want to reduce them michael
looks like he just got his heart broken
so now you you want to reduce the boost
along with the body tuna angela went on
to explain that this
is for the sake of her health she even
revealed that the weight of her chest
makes it hard for her to breathe at
times
which is on a whole nother level so how
michael feels about his fun toys at this
point
is irrelevant they'll be up perky
but you won't be able to pull on like
you like
michael oh god the introduction is just
literally right i don't know
you're more concerned about the size of
my damn boobs than you
are of my health if my boobs turn out
too small
this can really be bad for me and
michael's relationship
one i'm gonna be pissed that he don't
love me for me
and two you didn't marry me because of
my big boobs did you
or did you i don't know angela
based off of what michael is saying it
seems like that was at least one of the
reasons
as i mentioned earlier this news got
michael so upset
that he called his older brother over to
vent and his brother
i think unknowingly gave him the
straight side eye
for a minute when he first sat down he
came in knowing that this conversation
was about to be wild
why did she insist on doing the surgery
in the first place nigeria mean
valuable big boobs it is something to be
proud of no it shows a sign of good
living and the husband
takes good care of his wife and when she
she have
that kind of a non-stature it's part of
the reason why i got attractive to
angela
on first day you know i saw a puffer
picture
i love it okay this is something that
you can't be
mad at this is how he was raised it's
his culture
now we know that his love for her boobs
is way deeper
than the surface although i don't think
that's gonna make angela feel any better
honestly i don't know if it will make me
feel any better because
in my mind it just sounds like you still
care too much about my boobs
in africa yeah it is here we have
hundred percent control of our wives
this woman is coming from another
culture over there they have
freedom it's quite different but all
this
looking more pretty looking more sexier
this is woman we are talking about
because after this surgery
she will look more younger but
definitely other men too will also be
looking at her
and they also want to they should close
their eyes
they should close that what is what is
most important is for her to close the
heart towards
towards those men we just have to be
very very careful because american women
are independent yes we are
[Applause]
do you know what that means and yes i
just hit you with that throwback
you know it was actually sweet when
michael said the men who look at angela
should close their eyes
in a weird way it makes me feel like his
love for her is genuine
it does all right i've talked about
boobs
way too much today more than i ever have
in public in my life
so i'm gonna go but before i do let's
take a look at what happens with angela
next week
angela you're just waking up you're all
done with your procedure
can you open your eyes open your eyes
for me
i think the thing that makes angela
nervous is not waking up
and
[Music]
open your eyes to me open your eyes
that is scary thankfully once again we
know she's okay
but wow what a tease all right 90 day
fans fam
make sure you stick with e.t because as
usual we
are covering it all i will see you next
[Music]
time